네, 안녕하세요. 어, 여기 어디
사옥? 오늘은 디자인 A3 4옥에 와
있습니다.이 건물 위치가 선정
능력에서 도보 한 5분 정도 거리에
위치하고 있어 가지고 역세권에 위치한
건물입니다. 디자인에 굉장히 신경을
많이 썼거든요. 그래서 한번 제가
들어가서 디자인에서는 과연 어떻게
사을 만들었는지 한번 보여 드리도록
하겠습니다. 가시죠.
네. 아, 간단하게 자기 소개 좀
부탁드리겠습니다.
>> 네. 안녕하세요. 공간 디자인 회사
운영하고 있는 디자인 A3의
유영훈입니다. 반갑습니다.
>> 아, 반갑습니다.이 공간 좀 소개 좀
해 주세요.
>> 어, 여기는 저희 회사의 맨
탑층이고요.이 입점사들 전체 회의하고
가끔 파티 대관하고 저희도 가끔
회의를 하고 그러는 공간입니다. 한
18평밖에 안 되거든요. 음.
>> 근데 조폭 길잖아요. 1조 세선 제한
받아서. 그러다 보니까 여기만 이렇게
확장되게끔 예. 이렇게이 밑에 하브
레일이 밑으로 심어져 있거든요.
전체가 확장되면은이 공간이 한 두 배
정도를 활용할 수 있게 요렇게 만든
거예요.
>> 여기가 일단 돼지가 한 77평
정도.
>> 예. 77.8평.
>> 옆면적은 지금 몇 평이에요?
>> 옆면적 279평인데이
테라스를 제가 다 좀 크게 크게 다
뺐잖아요. 테라스 공간이 면적이 한평
돼요.
>> 실제 공사할 때는 한 300평을 지은
거죠.
>> 공사 기간은 얼마 남계? 실제 공사
기간이 19개월이에요. 실제로 딱
집중해서 했던 기간은 한 15,
6개월 정도 된다고 보면 되겠네요.
>> 설계도 오래 걸리셨죠?
>> 네. 설계 23년도 5월 달에 제가
계약했잖아요. 그에 몇 말까지
>> 했어요?네. 공사비는 대량
>> 공사비가 저는 이제 이쪽 업에
있으니까요. 제가 지출한 금액을
말씀드리면 건축 공사비 30억
인테리어 비용으로 3억 6천 설계 또
기타 등등의 비용이 한 5억 원 정도
된 거 같아요.
>> 어 사실 저도 이제 막 검을 많이
보잖아요. 보면은이 정도 완성도의
퀄리티 치고는 그래도 가격이 괜찮은
거 같아요.
>> 이제 흔히들 좀 착각하는 거 중에
연면적이라 하면 단순하게 270평에
대한 공사비라고 생각하잖아요.
테라스도 그 공사비에 전부는 아니지만
한 반 이상은 나오는 거 같아요.
비용이. 그래서 그런 테라스의 비용을
좀 감안해야 돼요. 물론 조경 비용도
좀 들 수 있겠죠?이
[음악]
>> 엘리베이터의 디자인이 좀
중요했거든요.
>> 어, 네. 네.
>> 스탠 비드거든요. 비드. 그니까
유광도 아니고 무광도 아닌
>> 음.
>> 이것도 스탠이거든요. 이거 스탠인데
이걸 스탠 바이브레이션이라고 해요.
스탠을 막 이렇게 갈아낸 거 같은
느낌.요 도어 있죠? 도어도 약간
외장재랑 비슷한 느낌이죠? 아,
그러네요.요 재질이 저 위에 있는
재질하고이 바닥 재질하고 같거든요.
>> 아, 네.
>> 보시면 질감이 요렇고요.요 소재가
여기 엘리베이터의 이런 게이트에도
같이 들어가 있죠. 이게 화이트
벽면이잖아요. 페인팅. 이제 코너
이런 데가 자기 훼손되고 떼 탈 수
있잖아요. 그래서 여기에도 같이
적용을 한 거예요.
>> 아,
>> 예. 유지 관리 보스 측면에서 좋을
것 같았어요.
저희 건물에서는 이제 계단실
엘리베이터 내리면 여기 양쪽으로
화장실을 뺐거든요. 근데 저는 요새
건물 화장실이 좀 중요하다는 생각이
>> 들더라고요.
>> 저도 진짜 완전 공감 설계를 하다
보면 화장실을 더게 조그맣게 뺄
수밖에 없거든요. 저희는 소변기를
넣어야 하니까 남자 화장실이 좀 더
크거든요. 그래서 요쪽이 남자
화장실입니다.
>> 네.
>> 남자 화장실이고. 예.
>> 아, 향기가 일단 너무 좋다.
>> 예.
>> 아. 아,요 세면대는 같은 이런
타일로 해서 제작을 한 거고 여긴 또
약간 화사.
>> 네. 화사하고 따뜻하고 요런 소재들도
다르죠. 화장실 이렇게 신경 써 주면
좋은 거 같아요.
>> 아, 그죠.
>> 그리고 저런 부분들
>> 저런 부분들이 바깥을 바라볼 수 있는
틈이잖아요.
>> 잠깐이지만 아, 뭐 비가 오네.
바람이 부는구나. 이런 것들을 보는
거죠.
>> 음. 여기 사무 공간입니다. 아,
>> 작은 사무 공간인데 여기서 이제
보시면 되게 재밌는게 의외로 창이
크면요. 저 블라인드를 계속 지금도
작은 창인데도 내려놓잖아요.
>> 대부분 모니터를 쓰니까 반사 때문에
>> 아, 그죠. 빛 많이 들어왔어요.
>> 네. 그래서 사무실이 창이 클 필요가
없다라는 걸 알았어요.
>> 만약에 창에 저 블라인드를 안
하잖아요. 근무할 수가 없어요. 결국
거의 내려놓잖아요. 그거 생각해서
저희는 그냥 창을 아예 작게 했어요.
그리고 창이 너무 크면요. 비용도 또
비싸요.
>> 맞아요. 맞아요.
>> 여기는
>> 아, 이게 제방입니다.
>> 음. 마찬가지로 여기 진무실인데
이렇게 바깥에 테라스 바로 보이고
바람 불면서 이렇게 나무님 흩날리고
하는 것들도 너무 좋더라고요. 보시면
프레임을 다 가렸어요. 돌로. 저
위에 물끊기를 해야 되잖아요. 그래서
돌이 3도 정도 이렇게 기울어
있어요. 물끊기가 없잖아요, 지금.
대신에 유리는 깨끗하죠? 돌에서 흐른
물이 유리에 흐르면 물대가 껴요.
근데 이렇게 물이 비가 치는 물은
물대가 끼지 않거든요. 네.
>> 아,
>> 그런 디테일이 필요합니다. 네.
>> 진짜 깨끗해요, 여기.
>> 예. 이게 또 턱이 있어서 그쪽으로
내려가는게 아니라 지금 보시면 여기가
더 높잖아요. 내부인데도
>> 약간 내려와 있잖아요. 그래서 요런
레벨들도 되게 체크를 잘하는 게
>> 중요하죠.맞.
>> 아, 네.
[음악]
여기 저희 사무실인데요.
>> 아, 마침 점심 시간이네요.
>> 아, 네. 아, 다행이네요.
>> 아. 아, 여기도 너무 쾌적하고
좋다.
>> 책장이
>> 네.
>> 이렇게 파티션 역할을 하는 거거든요.
>> 아,
>> 예. 두 개의 책상에 하나가 네.
>> 여기도 테라스.
>> 어,
>> 여기서 이제 나와서 보면 저 위쪽도
보이잖아요.
>> 예. 어떤 이런 실스들이 다 같이
이렇게 이어지니까 그런 건 되게 좋은
거 같아요.
>> 여기 이제 임대 공간입니다. 여기가
저희 건물에서는 지상층 중에서는 제일
넓은 면적인 거 같아요.
>> 아, 네.
>> 여기 테라스 보시면 이런 부분이
디테일이 진짜 어렵더라고요.
창호에서. 아,
>> 왜냐면 여기 이렇게 난간이 있고
여기는 밑으로 내려와야 되는 창이고
저긴 반창이고 할 때 요런 디테일들이
어려운 거 같아요. 근데 요런 부분들
자세히 보면 되게 잘 풀었어요.
프레임은 안에 있고 유리가 밖에
있거든요.
>> 아, 그러네요.
>> 깨끗하죠? 네.
>> 네.
>> 아, 이건 진짜 디테일들이
>> 여기가 이제 2층인 거죠? 예.
2층입니다. 2층인데 이렇게 주변에
있는 그런 이런 화단들이 눈에
들어와서
>> 되게 좀 편안하게 그냥 이렇게 있을
수 있는 거 같아요.
>> 아, 여긴 참 크게 잘 내진 거
같아요.
>> 여기는 전체 3면을
>> 음
>> 웬만하면 이제 통창으로
>> 맞춰도 냈고
>> 음,
>> 여기 좀 독특한게 이쪽으로 한 2m
정도, 저쪽으로 1m 1m 80 정도
첨화가 있거든요. 이게 위층 바닥인
거죠. 저게 이제 비를 막아 줘요.
여기 이제 청화 역할을 해 주는
거죠. 여기는 지금 카페로 설계
중이거든요. 바깥이 그냥 혼이 보이는
높이 정도로 되어 있습니다. 지하가
볼까요, 이제?
>> 네. 예, 지하 가보세.
[음악]
>> 여기 이제 지하 2층이거든요. 여기서
되게 중요한게 있는데이 보 있죠?
보.이 보를 기준으로 보 밑으로
내려와 있는 배관이 하나도 없어요.
>> 이걸 뚫 뚫었구나.
>> 아니, 안 뚫었어요. 처음부터이
열교환기 있죠? 열교환기. 그다음에
에어컨. 네. 예. 관을 미리 관통
슬리브를했어요.
>> 그래서 보 안에 이렇게 슬립을
매설하고
>> 밑으로 보강을 했죠.
>> 아,
>> 그래서 하나도 뚫은 건 없어요.
>> 예. 깨끗하잖아요.
>> 네. 네. 아, 그니까 타공을 한게
아니에요.
>> 아, 여기도 너무 좋다.
>> 어, 지금은 좀 덜한데 오전에는 제가
저기 이렇게 뚫었잖아요.
>> 그 유리난간 저쪽 옆면 벽을
>> 상부를 뚫은 이유가
>> 오전역에 해가 여기까지 이렇게
들어오더라고요.
>> 아,
>> 그래서 여기를 다 통창으로 하고
>> 성글성글한 계단으로 설계하고
>> 저 위에 유리 난간으로 하고
>> 그다음에 그 위를 뚫은 거예요.
그래서 여기 채광이 좀 들어오게 지하
>> 진짜 불빛 들어올 때 진짜 그
>> 어
>> 여기가 좀 있어요. 여기가
>> 나름 아
>> 예 예
>> 한번 올라가 볼까요? 네네
>> 네
>> 어 여기가 이제 주출입구잖아요. 약간
슬로프가 있어요.
>> 30cm 정도 슬로프가 있는데 그
덕에 여기를 지하로 인정받을 수 있던
거죠. 여기 보시면이 도로 경계석
있잖아요. 저희 건물이 많이 뒤로
밀려서 지었어요. 동네의 골목이지만
좀 여유가 있거든요. 그덕에 이제
이런 밑에서 바라보는이 건물의 민면
있죠?
>> 이런 밑면이 많이 보여요.
>> 아,
>> 건물을 바라보는 건 밑에서 위로
바라볼 때 아름다워야 한다라는
기준으로 설계를 한 거예요. 실을.
그러다 보니까 제일 단순하게 찾았어야
됐고 쉐이블을. 그래서 이제 그런
디테일들 때문에 건물이 강결해
보이죠?
>> 네. 진짜 너무 잘 둘러봤고 확실히
진짜 디자인 회사 닿게 제가 본 건물
중에 정말 손꼽힐 정도로 아 거의
최고 수준으로이 정도 규모로 진짜
이렇게 해밀하게 신경 쓴 건물 진짜
처음 봤고 저희 진짜 약간 감동이
몰려
>> 만약에 진짜이 영상을 보시는 4혹을
뭐 신축이나 인테리어 하고 싶다라고
하시면은 꼭 A3 업체에 문의 주시면
너무 좋을 거 같고 촬영해 봤는데 좀
간단하게 소한 말씀 말씀드네.
>> 네. 별산남 김민수 대표님 통해서
저희가이 땅을 샀고 지금 편안한
상태에서 근무하고 있는데 모든이
과정들이 좀 힘들긴 했습니다만 또
원하는 장면들이 나와서 이런 공간이
있다는게 너무 감사하고 기록으로 남길
수 있는 오늘 시간 너무 좋았습니다.
>> 아, 네. 감사합니다.
>> 그래서 오늘 출연해 주셔서 감사드리고
어 오늘 영상은 여기까지 하겠습니다.
감사합니다.
>> 네. 감사합니다.
[음악]